it's been 6 years but Arlene giaga still
gets emotional when asked about her
husband's death she says she saw him
being shot by police but was forced to
sign an affidavit stating
otherwise it says that I was at
neighbors and was surprised to return
and find my husband dead but I signed it
to protect my children Arlene is one of
several relatives of the victims of
so-called drugar killings interviewed by
idea
a group of human rights lawyers the
organization found that while the
government says it's investigating
dozens of cases only five families out
of a 100 surveyed were approached and
none have been able to file cases in
court their main interaction with State
actors was the the murder of the
relatives so how could they trust the
same institutions there have only been
two convictions so far one in the case
of 17-year-old de los Santos his remains
were exhumed from the cemetery in Manila
last year now is the site of what will
be known as The Shrine of healing a
memorial for the thousands killed during
the war against drug crime under the
administration of former president rodri
dette has broken ground an earned with
the names of some of the victims has
been buried underneath human rights
Advocates say they were killed without
the benefit of du process the
international criminal court has stepped
in and while President Ferdinand Marcus
Jr is adamant it is no authority to
investigate local cases Congress has
passed a resolution urging authorities
to cooperate there is also a question
should be returned uh under the fold of
the ICC so that's again under study in
the meantime these lawyers say they
intend to keep helping victims navigate
the domestic justice system and have
proposed expanding the government's
Witness Protection Program Barner below
Al jaaz
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz